no yeah i saw the matrix trailer as well
and i you know when when we started i
guess so i'm i'm you you brought up the
matrix so joey brought up seeing the
matrix yeah i saw the trailer for the
matrix resurrections i think it's called
yeah yeah i i'm going to be honest with
you i've watched all the matrix movies
and i cannot remember what happened in
any of them me neither i kind of have
because i went on a stint of watching
matrix clips like for some random not
the movies not the movies the clips and
i'm just like man i think the second and
third movie were way better than what i
remember because i was watching these
flips yeah i was watching the clips um
this is just how i experienced movies
nowadays john literally doesn't watch
movies can't watch his one-fifth of a
movie and decides if he likes the movie
or not and then never watches it i can't
i can't believe we're about to live
vicariously through youtube cuz cause
like i just watched i just watched the
best parts of the movies and the great
thing about watching the best parts of
the movies is that you get to blank out
all the [ __ ]
it just makes the movie look way better
so i remember saying in our movie
episode that i don't think the matrix
has aged well at all yeah and i think i
i think there was like so many little
things that i didn't um that i didn't
really understand when i first watched
the matrix trilogy right apparently the
co-director said that it was a metaphor
for being trans the whole movie series
what
really yeah well i mean the wachowski
brothers did yeah
i you know again this is this is just
something i read and i was like oh i
don't know that oh okay yeah cool but i
mean i don't know
yeah i mean what i found what i found
was really cool was how the entire world
was kind of like built like you know
like a program and i didn't realize at
the time when i watched it as a kid that
basically every character like every
character like represented a different
program or a different
uh a different subsystem of the matrix
and i'm just like oh there was so much
thought that went into this about matrix
law that just [ __ ] flew over my head
as a kid i'm just like oh cool people go
bang bang bang people
yeah yeah
that's all i care about
that's all i cared about as a kid and i
i realized when i was like watching
these clips and like watching videos
about matrix lore and like how
and what did you get what was yours in
our youtube essay about why the matrix
is good and and you should care
no i watched uh i i was only about four
hours it was two hours actually it was
only about four hours thank you very
much i needed someone to tell me what to
think about the movie because
that's why i watch gigger
so do you think it needs a new movie do
you want a new movie of matrix i mean i
wasn't expecting it but you know what i
am curious if i were to be honest
if it makes counter happy i'm fine with
it i don't think i understand that i
think there is space for a new movie
the problem is i don't remember how the
third movie ends the third movie ends
spoiler alert uh
for a 20 year old uh yeah for a tony
orton with
and agent smith fighting yeah and you
know there's they're they're doing like
the superman [ __ ] yeah and then agent
smith like i forgot like what he like
puts his hand into neo he becomes agent
smith and then neo dies because and then
yeah and i was here
and then he uh and then humans and
machines live in harmony
and uh the matrix is saved and uh that's
it it's remade and i think that's the
movie so how would you go on from that
question i i i i can't remember what the
trailer of the plot was it's just very
confusing yeah i just think there is
like because
that's what got me into it because i saw
the trailer now i remember because i was
like how are they gonna make a fourth
movie and so they got me to look into
the original trilogy this is why ghana
both wanted man
i'm like i'm like i'm like retracing my
steps to why i started watching matrix
players and it was because of the fourth
trailer and uh i think there is space
because there is space more storytelling
with different iterations of the matrix
and i think that was one really
interesting part of the matrix that was
never been able to was never explored in
the original which was this was just one
version of the matrix yeah so they were
like there could be plenty of others and
there could be plenty of others in the
future so there's
so many ways you can so what you're
saying is it could turn into like a fate
situation
no no no no no i did not say that i did
not say
you said there were multiple universes
multiple timelines and all i could think
of was oh it's just like it's like fate
there's a moon yeah they have a moon
oh my okay so
here's
i want to watch the movie yeah but i
understand that i have to go back and
watch the other three yeah and i don't
think you do though no really no no
i kind of want to though but i feel like
i would miss so much yeah the point of
the movie but then also re-watching the
other movies you can't not pay attention
if you it's one of those movies you look
away at your phone for one second you're
like rewind that two minutes please yeah
um i i know yeah i do want to watch it i
just don't it's time yeah yeah i mean
it's it was it was a different it was
like it was a different
uh experience going like revisiting the
matrix like i kind of realized how much
of an amazing character morpheus is now
and that makes me really sad that they
didn't get laurence fishbone to uh oh
yeah they didn't did that come back as
morpheus even though they got like the
main is there a reason why is i think
because they're doing young morpheus in
this one so i mean it might be might be
a plot point
he wasn't john wick was he and johnny
and john wick is he joined he's in john
wick
yeah i did like that keanu reeves
basically just like it was just
basically john was given up
like i'm gonna contradict myself to my
point earlier where i said that i don't
watch movies because the actors i yeah i
will watch almost anything with keanu
reeves just because he's such a delight
to watch oh yeah like you guys just have
he always you can tell he loves it it's
also cool to think that in real life
he's also really chill yeah yeah you
know i know it's like the thing that you
do when you're when you're on the
internet to just adore keanu reeves but
like legitimately like when he's on
screen i love watching him yeah yeah
yeah
i genuinely feel that he loves every
second of performing oh yeah and it's
just a delight to watch yeah absolutely
sometimes it's just nice to see someone
who loves something that they do
like let's see someone who loves their
job you know i don't know it's it's it's
it's the little things in life
you know even when he's doing these
characters you can just tell like
through it but yeah yeah i don't know
why i don't know how you can do that but
it works but i don't know why but keanu
reeves seems like the kind of guy who
would like collect much of the movies
yeah
he's like that kind of guy right he's
like dude i got this john week action
figures [ __ ] john wick is like some
of my most enjoyable theater experiences
like every single time i've gone to
watch it in the movie theaters i've just
had such a [ __ ] delight i've only
seen the first one honestly
the first one as well yeah please watch
the other two they're so funny
really good movies let's see the episode
watch some work just go watch sean wick
walk so much right now yeah